Speaker 1: . I want to talk to you today about
what I'm calling the nexus the intersection
of immoral and stupid.
And when I hear the nexus of immoral and stupid,
I think about a handful of members of Congress.
And on that list is Republican Matt Gates.
Matt Gates is voting against capping insulin
prices to the end user.
Now it's crazy to use the term end user.
When we're talking about medicine, I agree
with you.
It's also a crazy situation because we are
only talking about capping the price of insulin
for the end user.
So late last week, the House of Representatives
passed a Democratic sponsored bill to cap
insulin at $35 a month for most Americans
in terms of their out of pocket.
Now, of course, you know, and I know and anybody
who's dealt with health insurance knows these
things cost way more, but health insurance
will pay part of it.
And then there's a discount and blah blah
blah blah blah.
I know some of you were sick of this example,
but it's been at least six months since since
I've made it an example when I had my infamous
appendectomy.
You might remember that the sticker price
was thirty five grand.
Now that's what the hospital billed.
My insurance, my insurance had said Sirs and
M&Ms at the hospital.
We know people sometimes have appendicitis.
Will you contract with us for appendectomies
for I believe it was $11000.
So of the thirty something thousand that the
hospital wanted, my insurance said we are
OK with 11 and I had a $2000 deductible.
So the $35000 appendectomy ended up being
2000 for me and my insurance made up that
other $9000.
Similarly, with insulin, you know there are
people now who pay over a thousand dollars
a month in the price, the actual price of
insulin.
My SRP sticker price wouldn't even change
with this bill.
But the point here is insulin guys insulin
$35 a month.
Let's cap it.
And Matt Gates says no.
Why does Matt Gates say no?
Basically, because people should just lose
weight.
He wrongly thinks not that it would really
make a big difference, but he wrongly thinks
only overweight people need insulin.
Matt Matt Gates saying quote While Democrat
posturing of H.R. 60 833 victimizes insulin
pays as people with an uncontrollable disease
that are being taken advantage of and need
Big Brother to throw them a raft, lifestyle
changes and mass would expeditiously lower
demand and the subsequent prices of insulin
90 to 95 percent of people with diabetes have
type two, which can be prevented or delayed
with healthy lifestyle changes such as losing
weight, eating healthy food and being active.
Arbitrary price controls are no substitute
for individual weight control.
Since 2000, the number of diabetes cases in
the U.S. has nearly doubled.
The demand for insulin has increased and the
requisite price increase has followed suit.
In other words, the price of insulin increases
as waistlines increase.
So yes, he's a prick.
Yes, of course, but he's also ignorant.
Aside from this being asinine and disgusting
and just horrible, it's not accurate.
Type one diabetes is managed by taking insulin
to control blood sugar.
Type two diabetes in more ways than type one
is managed in other ways.
This means medication.
This means exercise.
This means diet.
When I say medication, I mean a pill, not
insulin.
People with type two.
Diabetes sometimes are prescribed insulin,
but insulin is about type one diabetes.
Insulin is for type one diabetes, who are
often perfectly fit.
It is for type one diabetes for people who
are not overweight.
And there's a couple of different things here,
and I don't even know where to start, to be
totally honest, guys.
I mean, on the one hand.
Should absolutely no condition related to
our own actions be covered, because then we're
saying we're not covering lung cancer, most
of which is related to cigaret smoking.
We're not covering injuries that happen as
a result of what we might call extreme sports
or risky activities.
We're not covering COVID stays for people
who are unvaccinated.
I mean, so first of all, is this is this idea
that, hey, listen, I want people to live as
healthy lifestyle as possible, but are we
really saying we shouldn't be covering costs
for people who have certain conditions because
of how those conditions develop?
That seems very, very dangerous.
No.
Now, as I've said before, people will say,
but David, sir, didn't you say that if we
have a full E.R. and you need to start putting
COVID patients on ventilators, it seems OK
as part of triaging limited resources to say
the vaccinated people get the ventilator first
because they're more likely to survive and
they're more likely to follow medical directions
as to their care.
That is different than saying you're just
not covered if you have type two diabetes,
so that's number one.
Number two, you know, we've talked before
about obesity seen as basically a moral failing.
So putting aside that insulin is mostly for
type one and Matt Gates is talking about type
two, this idea that we can only see we should
only see obesity as a moral failing is is
wrong.
At the same time, it should be OK to say that
in the United States, lack of nutritional
education leads people to eat persistently
unhealthy diets for their entire lives.
And we've got to be able to talk about that
as well.
But when we talk about obesity, we're talking
about sometimes diet, sometimes genetic factors,
sometimes underlying disease.
There's a lot of different things.
And again, seeing obesity as the big moral
failing also is extraordinarily myopic.
So and the fat shaming and stuff like that
does not appear to work.
Matt Gates is discussing insulin should be
cheap to the end user.
Maybe we call them the end customer or whatever
the case may be, and he's vital for voting
against this, and he's vile for his reasoning
as well.